merci d'être avec nous pendant cette
première demi-heure Jean-François ils
sont vous êtes sénateur les républicains
de la Meurthe-et-Moselle rapporteur
général du budget dont on va évidemment
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord l'actualité dans votre
partie c'est évidemment cette élection à
la présidence eriki et Bruno Retailleau
sont donc qualifiés pour le second tour
quelle était votre réaction hier à
l'annonce des résultats d'abord il y a
une satisfaction c'est la participation
quasiment trois adhérents sur 4 ce qui
est énorme puisque plus de 90 000
adhérents nous sommes le premier parti
de France c'est au moins une
satisfaction et le fait qu'il y ait eu
finalement ce temps de campagne avec un
panorama qui est nouveau il faut pas se
le cacher c'est une finalement c'est une
étape nouvelle je ne sais pas dire si
c'est de construction ou de
reconstruction qui nous attend mais ça
c'est la première bonne nouvelle et puis
la seconde c'est bah il y a un deuxième
tour preuve que
comment dirais-je cette compétition
finalement a aussi motivé et mobiliser
et finalement chacun des trois
prétendants à trouver une place et de
toute façon une place plus ou moins
importante que ce qui pouvait avoir été
pronostiqué les deux candidats ont
beaucoup parlé de rassemblement il y en
a qui est plus rassembleur que l'autre
pour vous il y en a je connais plus que
l'autre
on connaît le je dirais le parcours de
Bruno le taillot une chose est certaine
en tant que présidente de du groupe les
républicains au Sénat il a eu l'occasion
depuis des années de démontrer sa
capacité à écouter à entendre et à ne
pas arbitrer
uniquement selon ses propres convictions
je crois que c'est un atout sur le
nécessaire esprit d'ouverture qui doit
présider à notre partie je connais tout
à fait honnêtement moins Éric Ciotti
c'est d'ailleurs
moi ma sensibilité naturelle
j'espère que
nous saurons être les gardiens d'un
parti qui justement soit toujours en
capacité de s'ouvrir et en s'ouvrant
nécessairement on a aussi cette capacité
de trouver plusieurs sensibilités et de
faire en sorte qu'elle rassemble la
France a besoin aujourd'hui à la fois de
comment dirais-je d'ouverture de
diversité d'opinions être capacité à
rassembler je crois que c'est vraiment
très important et en France évidemment
la droite et le Centre ont
impérieusement besoin à la fois de se
renouveler de proposer un projet
d'alternance vous resterez dans le
participe en porte
on verra dimanche prochain chaque chose
en son temps et puis je crois que le
choix des uns des autres s'inscrit aussi
dans le parcours et l'image que l'on
entend donner à la fois de l'engagement
public il faut chacun est la capacité de
ses coups de s'écouter et puis il faut
intégrer les différences mais jusqu'où
jusqu'où il faut s'ouvrir et de quel
côté il faut s'ouvrir surtout moi je
pense qu'il faut s'ouvrir
je suis un homme de la droite plutôt
indépendante libérale
et que juste est également démocrate
chrétienne je suis un espèce de 4K je
l'ai toujours dit et je l'assume donc
vous le voyez je suis plus dans dans le
centre droit clairement assumé parce que
je crois qu'il faut regarder également
l'avenir autrement que uniquement par
exemple sur l'origan le régalien c'est
un sujet mais moi je vois des sujets de
société la question de je dirais de
l'allongement de durée de vie qui fait
que une fois qu'on a cessé son activité
plus on avance en âge on a le sujet de
l'isolement et puis on a un sujet majeur
qui transcende les sensibilité politique
qui est qui touche aux questions
environnementales et écologique
on va en parler on va parler du budget
de l'écologie mais un mot puisque vous
parlez de la droite et du centre on a vu
pendant l'examen du budget à plusieurs
reprises la majorité sénatoriale droite
et sont de se fissurer ne pas être
d'accord le groupe centriste le groupe
n'est républicain pardon n'était pas
d'accord sur plusieurs sujets elle est
en train de se fissurer cette majorité
sénatoriale il faut surtout pas qu'elle
se fissure mais effectivement je comment
dirais j'ai un peu à titre personnel
j'ai souffert du fait que nous ne soyons
pas en capacité à ce moment-là de
trouver la voie de la Concorde on a eu
quelques sujets je trouve que c'est
dommage donc il faut il faut vite tirer
certains enseignements parce que nous
devons
les enseignements c'est d'essayer de
faire en sorte de mieux je dirais caler
nos positions et trouver les points de
convergence en amont
on va parler justement d'écologie de
budget d'examen du budget vie ces
dernières heures le vote aura lieu
demain on va revenir sur ces dernières
heures je séance avec Alex Pusa
[Musique]
bonjour
et Alex le Sénat a adopté le budget de
l'écologie dans un débat assez tendu
alors cette année le but du budget de
l'écologie c'est de faire face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et la
principale arme utilisée par le
gouvernement c'est le fameux bouclier
tarifaire qui se prolonge pour l'an
prochain et qui doit limiter à 15% la
hausse de la facture énergétique des
particuliers et puis à cela s'ajoute
l'amortisseur électricité qui va faire
lui baisser la facture énergétique des
PME et des collectivités de dispositifs
qui auront un coût net pour l'état de 9
milliards d'euros alors les sénateurs
sont plutôt favorables sur le papier ils
disent très bien pourquoi pas mais le
problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas eu du
tout toutes les informations du
gouvernement sur ces dispositifs alors
dans le débat ils étaient un petit peu
en colère d'autant que sur le terrain il
y a une réelle inquiétude sur les
conséquences de cette envolée des prix
de l'énergie on va écouter le sénateur
de droite Fabien Genet
vraiment le sentiment que nous sommes
assis sur une bombe une bombe
énergétique on a le sentiment qu'elle
n'a peut-être pas encore explosé en 2022
parce que effectivement il y a eu il
faut le reconnaître un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont déjà été prises par le
gouvernement et par le l'État et on peut
les saluer même si elles ne sont
certainement pas toutes parfaites mais
sur le terrain on a vraiment le
sentiment que 2023 ça va être le
véritable rendez-vous voilà donc un
bouclier tarifaire adopté mais avait
quand même beaucoup d'inquiétudes et
puis l'une des mesures fortes votées
dans ce débat sur le budget de
l'écologie par la majorité de droits de
sénatoriales et bien elle concerne elle
est prime pour acheter une voiture
électrique les sénateurs ont réduit de
500 millions d'euros le budget dédié à
cette conversion vers un véhicule
électrique car elle estime que pour
l'instant et bien cela finance surtout
l'industrie automobile chinoise écoutez
Christine Lavarde
aujourd'hui nous observons comme
l'ajustement dit Monsieur Dominati une
sorte de distorsion l'argent des
Français vient financer l'industrie
automobile chinoise alors c'est un
industrie automobile elle est en pointe
elle représente une part très
significative de la chaîne de valeur du
véhicule électrique 50 % et 75 % de la
chaîne de valeur des batteries donc
autant dire que sur ce secteur nous
avons abandonné notre souveraineté un
gouvernement qui a quand même reconnu
qui a moyen terme effectivement c'est
primes à la conversion devait aller sur
des véhicules européens et puis enfin on
peut noter que le Sénat a voté une
enveloppe supplémentaire de 150 millions
d'euros pour rénover notre réseau
ferroviaire Jean-François Husson il
fallait voter ce bouclier tarifaire cet
amortisseur électricité face à la bombe
énergétique qui s'annonce je cite votre
collègue Fabien Genet oui il y a pas je
dirais il y a pas de choix d'ailleurs je
crois que ce qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui
c'est faire en sorte de mettre les bons
dispositifs et surtout de bien préparer
les choses vous venez de montrer dans
votre reportage par exemple Christine
Havard de l'occasion de montrer que dans
la limite de 4% de l'ancien bouclier
tarifaire pour les particuliers
qu'est-ce qui s'est caché derrière ça
c'est le fait que par exemple dans les
heures pleines pour dans certains cas
les tarifs n'ont augmenté que de 1 ou 2
% et dans les heures creuses donc celles
vers lesquelles on oriente de manière
prioritaire les consommateurs les
augmentations tarifaires sont allées
parfois jusqu'à 15%. c'est inacceptable
ce qui démontre que il a manqué à mon
avis de lien entre les orientations du
gouvernement et les opérateurs comment
voulez-vous que les Français s'y
retrouvent et qui surtout qu'ils
acceptent finalement ce revers par
rapport à un objectif de
4%. vous faites l'effort et vous êtes
pénalisé ça n'est pas acceptable donc
des dispositifs à affiner est-ce que ce
ce qui est tarifaires c'est et puis cet
amortisseur vont assez loin notamment
pour les entreprises les collectivités
car la part c'est vraiment pour les
particuliers je crains que l'amortisseur
électricité soit insuffisant je le dis
depuis le début le fait d'être plutôt
avec une copie cachée de la part du
gouvernement donc à plusieurs reprises
moi je me suis adressé auprès des
partenaires sociaux notamment
économiques nous dit ben on fait
confiance on n'a pas trop de visibilité
on l'a vu d'ailleurs le gouvernement est
venu dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
avec un dispositif dont on a eu
connaissance 48 heures avant on est
l'occasion de dire à la ministre que ça
n'était pas acceptable alors ça n'est
pas acceptable et pourtant nous l'avons
voté oui parce qu'on pense qu'il faut
d'abord je dirais montrer un front uni
de la classe politique pour mettre en
place les moyens mais on a demandé et la
ministre s'y est engagée donc maintenant
j'attends mais on a demandé à suivre moi
par mois la mise en place de ces
dispositifs de mon point de vue je vais
vous dire Bouteiller encore dans une
boulangerie à Nancy ou
le la famille qui est à la tête de cette
boulangerie m'expliquait budget annuel
énergie 40000 budget l'an prochain entre
140 et 150.000 euros augmentation
nécessaire rien que pour l'énergie entre
15 et 20 % sur l'ensemble des produits
il me disent ça ne tiendra pas d'autant
qu'il y a des vrais problèmes de main
d'oeuvre donc c'est il y a comme ça un
certain nombre de français et de
catégories sociales qui sont très
inquiets donc sur le monde économique
dans le soutien à cette facture
énergétique pour l'instant on n'y est
pas mais je pense je pense que il y aura
certainement besoin effectivement de
corriger parce que grosso modo on
s'aperçoit que avec l'amortisseur
électricité on va couvrir à peu près 25%
de l'augmentation par rapport
aujourd'hui moi je pense que cette c'est
sûrement trop faible et il faut faire
très attention parce que la question les
questions d'énergie c'est globalement
aujourd'hui les Français vont y être
confrontés une à deux fois à partir du
mois de janvier pourquoi parce que
d'abord ils sont particuliers sur leur
consommation personnelle et deuxièmement
dans leur entreprise il y a rien de donc
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à garder
dans toute la mesure du possible des
capacités de produire mais ça renvoie un
vrai sujet pourquoi on est arrivé là moi
je ne peux pas ne pas dénoncer les
errements et les renoncements des dix
dernières années où les gouvernants sous
Hollande et Macron 1 ont expliqué que le
nucléaire c'était une histoire de dingue
que c'était complètement dépassé on
allait mettre des éoliennes du
photovoltaïque mais on voit que on peut
être très cher et quand en plus vous
avez un des incidents techniques liés à
la corrosion et bien finalement on se
retrouve comment dirais-je en panne ce
qui est vraiment vraiment dommage et moi
je ne peux pas passer sous silence cette
responsabilité qui colle aux deux
quinquennats François Hollande et
Emmanuel Macron
pardon elle est juste sur pour finir sur
la question de l'énergie le gouvernement
pour les prépare un plan de coupure cet
hiver justement pour faire face à la
baisse de la production Emmanuel Macron
hier dans le Parisien dit pas de panique
ça vous rassure vous savez c'est
difficile de suivre le président de la
République qui vous explique qu'il y a
deux mois et demi que c'est la fin de
l'abondance qui a dit jour vous explique
que il y aura 10 métropoles avec des RER
qui l'a dit autre chose c'est le
président de la République
modestement à place qui est la mienne
moi j'attends du 1er République qui
donne un cap qu'il se situe finalement
non seulement au-dessus des parties mais
il est un peu normalement un guide pour
la nation aujourd'hui je ne sens pas ce
guide c'est plutôt du slalom et on a
l'impression qu'autour de lui il faut à
chaque fois faire des coups de com mais
les coudes comme ça fatigue ça ne
rassure pas il faut retrouver un cap
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir un
capitaine sur le navire France qui donne
la direction
Jean-François ils sont parlant des
voitures électriques puisque je le
disais les sénateurs ont réduit de 500
millions d'euros le budget dédié à ces
primes à la conversion alors on comprend
bien la question de la souveraineté face
à l'automobile chinoise mais quand même
est-ce que cette réduction ça ne va pas
ralentir la conversion de notre parc
automobile non je crois pas je pense
qu'il y a là aussi coup de com tout
électrique et finalement on s'aperçoit
que on oriente les Français vers des
achats qui sont à l'opposé de ce que de
ce qu'on souhaite
que ta carbone décarbonation de
l'économie et finalement c'est ce sont
des véhicules chinois que les Français
importent ou des je pense qu'il fallait
aller un peu moins vite dans la mutation
parce que les chaînes de production de
nos constructeurs automobiles et des
constructeurs situés en Europe c'est pas
dans un claquement de doigts donc comme
on n'arrive pas dans un claquement de
doigts il faut donner une progressivité
et je pense que là nous sommes coupables
on est aussi coupables en France de ma
prime rénove on met on jette l'argent la
rénovation thermique de la rénovation
des bâtiments ou en fait on s'aperçoit
que sous couvert de dire on a fait
beaucoup de dossiers voire on a même
comment dirais-je consommer beaucoup de
millions de d'euros on s'aperçoit en
fait que les gestes sont peu voire
inefficaces et bien ça ça n'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui chaque euro
dépensé doit être bien dépensé et
utilement également pour notre
environnement on arrive à la fin de la
discussion budgétaire Jean-François ils
sont quel bilan faites-vous de cette
discussion budgétaire est-ce que le
gouvernement était à l'écoute
le gouvernement est à l'écoute mais
je pense un budget d'une
occasion manquée l'occasion manquée
c'est de commencer à maîtriser la
dépense publique et finalement le
gouvernement
depuis quelques années d'ailleurs les
gouvernements se sont comment dirais-je
un peu fracassé sur l'opinion publique
on l'a vu alors on a eu l'épisode le
fameux des gilets jaunes et après sur
les crises sanitaires l'affaire des
masques etc fait que je le redis on
manque de sérénité le cap est difficile
à trouver et aujourd'hui le gouvernement
ne fait pas d'effort pour maîtriser la
dépense lui la maîtriser c'est quoi
c'est faire en sorte que nous accusions
moins de dettes pour pouvoir sortir de
la crise avec un fardeau allégé et si on
échappe c'est l'objectif du gouvernement
mais le problème c'est que on a un
commerce extérieur qui est dans une
situation catastrophique nous avons une
dette
public qui est énorme qui continue de
grandir et on a des niveaux de
prélèvement obligatoire qui nous mettent
quasiment en champion d'Europe avec ça
on a des beaucoup de difficultés pour
pouvoir sortir sereinement et je lis il
faut sortir avec un esprit de
compétition parce que aujourd'hui cette
compétition elle se situe entre les pays
et elle doit favoriser l'emploi
l'innovation la créativité de l'économie
française justement Emmanuel Macron fait
le lien entre la relance de l'économie
et la réforme des retraites a priorité
au travail pour justement faire face aux
dépenses vous êtes satisfait de ça c'est
une terrible erreur
les retraites c'est d'abord la garantie
à l'issue d'une vie de travail et sur
cette garantie il y a il faut marcher
sur deux pieds je le dis avec à la fois
sérénité gravité deux pieds c'est la
répartition lorsque je suis actif je
paie les retraites de celles et ceux qui
justement ne sont plus en activité
professionnelle ce qui veut dire que
quand nous arrivons à la retraite ça
n'est pas de la capitalisation c'est
justement ceux qui sont derrière nous
qui vont payer notre retraite raison
pour laquelle je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui commencer à introduire un
dispositif de capitalisation parce que
c'est ce qui va garantir avec le la
modification de la pyramide des âges
c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus d'inactif et
moins d'actifs quand on a il suffit de
faire du calcul mental quand on est
devant cette situation en responsabilité
nous devons poser les sujets sur la
table et ensuite il y a un dial avec
évidemment les forces vives les
représentants des salariés des
entreprises et les Français et là ce
temps de dialogue de capitalisation dans
le régime général pour vous moi en tout
cas j'y suis effectivement favorable je
pense qu'il faut mais avec je pense
également quelques un système
obligatoire je pense que dès qu'on
commence à travailler et notamment je
vais vous dire ce serait la meilleure
garantie pour les
petits les bas salaires
dernier mot pour finir sur ce budget
est-ce que un compromis vous semble
possible avec le gouvernement ou est-ce
que vous redoutez que tout peut
modifications soient balayées par un
probable 49-3 à l'Assemblée je ne suis
pas très optimiste sur le budget si on
pouvait garder quelques éléments je
crois j'espère parce que
le 49-3 à l'Assemblée en 2022 pose aussi
une question le Sénat doit-il examiner
le budget si c'est pour qu'il se fasse
balayer d'un verre de main la
responsabilité d'exécutif et sera grande
nous avons
débattu vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs sans
être dans la majorité à 100% toujours
sur la même ligne mais nous avons évacu
également avec l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale chez nous au
Sénat le gouvernement doit entendre
cette voix singulière mais constructive
au service de la France et de ses
territoires
merci Alex à tout à l'heure on parlera
de la course à la présidence des
République dans une demi-heure on va
aller voir l'actualité du côté de chez
vous maintenant Jean-François ils sont
va à Nancy on retrouve Michael des mots
chef de l'agence de l'Est Républicain du
côté de Nancy bonjour Michael merci
d'être avec nous dans votre journal dans
l'Est Républicain on apprend que les
nappes phréatiques commencent à se
régénérer après plusieurs mois de
sécheresse
bonjour Alors oui après 6 mois de
septembre
alors je voulais vous demander ce matin
monsieur sénateur comment aider demain
les collectivités face aux futurs
canicules
bonjour et bien d'abord premier élément
j'ai obtenu dans le dernier projet de
loi de finances rectificative de fin de
gestion 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour aider les
collectivités notamment sur la
résorption la remise en état de la
modernisation de leur réseau d'adduction
d'eau parce que la première chose c'est
que l'eau qu'on produit il faut éviter
de la perdre avant même qu'elle n'arrive
au robinet donc c'est un des éléments le
deuxième effectivement il est aussi
d'aider mais ça on le fait par exemple
dans le Grand Est avec
l'Agence de l'Eau rameuse on travaille
avec les collectivités et l'ensemble des
acteurs sur l'ensemble des bassins
versants pour faire en sorte de comment
dirais-je de garantir une une un bon
maintien des nappes phréatiques et de la
ressource en eau mais pour cela il y a
aussi besoin de faire attention à nos
modes de consommation et à nos pratiques
et dans tous les domaines dans le
domaine évidemment de la vie privée et
personnelle mais également dans la vie
économique donc l'eau est une ressource
dont on peut craindre qu'elle devienne
plus rares et donc nous devons éviter là
encore c'est la c'est comme avec les
carburants comme avec nos modes de
consommation il faut absolument éviter
le gaspillage justement le gouvernement
met en place un plan de sobriété
énergétique est-ce qu'il faut aussi
mettre en place un plan de sobriété pour
l'eau je pense que nous devons mais
d'ailleurs ça se met en place depuis un
certain temps je le redis au niveau des
6 agences de l'eau dans les territoires
vous savez les j'ai coutumes de dire
dans les territoires là où la
participation des élus est la plus
importante ce sont en général sur les
syndicats des eaux parce que c'est un
bien que qui est aujourd'hui
considérée comme acquis chez chaque
particulier mais il y a un siècle tout
le monde n'avait pas l'eau courante
aussi facilement que ça donc grande
attention et puis il faut regarder ce
qui est en train de se passer en termes
climatique donc on ne peut pas faire on
ne peut pas dire qu'on n'a pas des
alertes
sécurité alors que les cyberattaques
touchent les entreprises les hôpitaux
les collectivités mais aussi les
particuliers oui c'est notre dossier
région Lorraine du jour effectivement
les cyberattaques sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à Nancy il y a de grands
spécialistes de la question vous le
savez alors est-ce que les territoires
sont assez équipés juridiquement et
financièrement face à ce phénomène
probablement que non
il y a deux je dirais il y a peut-être
deux voies possibles une qui est d'avoir
une vision à partir de notamment de
l'État on a on a secrétaire d'État
Jean-Noël Barrault qui est plus
largement chargé du sujet donc il faut
avoir une vraie stratégie et puis on a
le domaine assurantiel qui aujourd'hui
ne peut pas bien pour voir aux garanties
en cas de cyberattaque ce qui démontre
que nous nous avons besoin de travailler
sur une meilleure connaissance et donc
des dispositifs de prévention dans ce
domaine qui est un domaine à la fois
nouveau qui est un domaine assez
difficile d'accès c'est-à-dire que pour
le grand public où on se sent démuni
parce que c'est à la fois un problème de
de formation et puis ce sont des
phénomènes tellement nouveaux qu'il faut
pouvoir les anticiper avec suffisamment
de personnes former et de spécialistes
mais là je pense qu'il va nous falloir
mettre des moyens on le voit pour
l'instant dans les établissements de
santé notamment parfois dans les
collectivités mais je pense et on le
sait dans le domaine des entreprises
l'activité économique pourraient se
trouver fortement perturbé par ces des
malheureusement ces attaques cyber merci
Mika comme la plupart de nos titres de
presse régionale ce matin c'est les
Bleus la victoire des Bleus toujours
d'attaque et cette photo de Kylian
Mbappe et Olivier Giroud à la Une de
l'Est Républicain merci Michael vous
avez regardé le match hier
la suite du parcours des Bleus d'abord
c'est une belle surprise cette équipe de
France il faut souhaiter que une fois de
plus des champs soient un peu le
magicien c'est à dire qu'il arrive à
composer avec les joueurs dont ils
dispose et pour je l'espère le plus beau
des parcours et puis aller chercher
cette troisième étoile
un dernier sur
un
Macron super agressive concernant
l'attitude des Américains du risque
d'affaiblir les entreprises européennes
et il propose de financer le Med in
Europe est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
ça
finalement on voit que avec les
l'internalisation l'internationalisation
de la mondialisation des échanges on a
ouvert très largement
l'économie au monde et nous ne luttons
pas tous avec les mêmes armes on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'Asie on peut parler
aussi de l'Inde on peut parler
évidemment des États-Unis et du
continent européen je pense
effectivement que nous avons besoin mais
ça fait un certain temps qu'on porte ses
idées au-delà de les porter il faut
maintenant les mettre en oeuvre on parle
de Kota carbone pour engager l'Europe
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique qui ne doit pas être l'ennemi
de l'économie du progrès et de la
croissance et la croissance est pas la
croissance pour la croissance c'est
aussi pour permettre à tout à chacun de
pouvoir s'épanouir dans sa vie et pour
ça il faut aussi avoir une économie en
bonne santé merci Jean conseil merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin suivra bien sûr
la fin de l'examen du budget le vote est
prévu demain ici au Sénat dans 20
minutes dans le club de territoire on va
parler de votre partie présidence des
républicains deux candidats qualifiés
pour le second tour Éric Ciotti arrivée
en tête et Bruno retaillod et lien
Pradier le troisième homme en position
de faiseur de roi n'a toujours pas pris
position on verra ça dans 20 minutes et
on en parle tout de suite avec notre
prochain invité c'est François-Xavier
Bellamy qui nous rejoint